[موسيقى]
ملكه بريطانيا الراحله اليزابيث الثانيه
تعرضت لعده محاولات اغتيال في الولايات
المتحده جميعها باءت بالفشل وثائقه صادره
حديثا عن مكتب التحقيقات الفيدرالي كشفت
ان العقول المدبره لهذه المحاولات كان يقف
وراءها الجيش الجمهوري الايرلندي اول
محاوله اغتيال تعود الى العام
1983 في ولايه عندما كانت الملكه وزوجها
الامير فيليب في زياره الى كاليفورنيا
حينها حذر ضابط شرطه المخابرات الامريكيه
من ان هناك رجلا يسعى للانتقام لابنته
التي قتلت برصاصه مطاطيه في ايرلندا
الشماليه
مخطط الرجل كان سيؤدي الى قتل الملكه
باستهداف يختي بريطانيا الملكي من فوق جسر
البوابه الذهبيه او بقتلها مباشره خلال
زيارتها لحديقه الوطنيه
اصل التوترات يرجع الى نهايه ستينات القرن
العشرين عندما عانت ايرلندا الشماليه حقبه
من العنف المميت عرفت باسم حقبه المشكلات
استمرت 30 سنه وقد وضعت بذرتها قرون من
الصراع بين ايرلندا الكاثوليكيه وانجلترا
البروتستانتيه
فمع اشتداد الصراع في ايرلندا الشماليه
ظلت الولايات المتحده في حاله تاهب قصوى
كلما زارها افراد العائله الملكه
البريطانيه لتجنب اي تداعيات على اراضيها
وخاصه بعد الكشف عن محاوله اغتيال اخرى
للملكه خلال زيارتها الى بوستن ونيويورك
في عام 1989
بعد ذلك بعامين كشفت الاستخبارات
الامريكيه عن مخاوفها من ان الجماعات
الايرلنديه حسب وصفها كانت تخطط للاحتجاج
رفضا لحضور اليزابيث الثانيه
وحتى خلال زيارتها للبيت الابيض عام
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات